you need cash right now what do you do
if you need some cash in a hurry but
have poor credit or no credit history
for 12 million Americans and Counting
you take out a payday loan it's usually
a few hundred dollars and do on your
next payday hence the name the industry
says the loans are supposed to get you
back on your feet on a one-time basis
but with stagnant wages across the
country seventy-six percent of users
come back to borrow again these loans
usually have very high interest rates
and if you can't pay them back on time
you're hit with added fees some people
get trapped in cycles of debt even
borrowing to pay back their payday loans
they'll argue that payday loans are
predatory others say they're filling a
need either way with more loan stores
out there than McDonald's many of them
open late it's tempting for people down
on their luck
you